hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
lektion 11 hört zu und spricht nach
das ist mein vater das ist mein vater er
heißt peter er heißt peter sein beruf
ist polizist sein beruf ist polizist
das ist meine mutter das ist meine
mutter sie hat
stefanie sie heißt stefanie ihr beruf
ist verkäuferin ihr beruf ist
verkäuferin das ist mein bruder das ist
mein bruder
er heißt michael er heißt michael seine
jacke ist blau seine jacke ist blau
[Musik]
das ist meine schwester
das ist meine schwester sie hat
astana sie heißt anna ihre jacke ist
rosa ihre jacke ist rosa mein großvater
heißt hans mein großvater heißt hans er
trägt eine brille
er trägt eine brille
seine haare sind grau sein
meine großmutter heißt erika meine
großmutter heißt erika sie ist 69 jahre
alt
sie ist 69 jahre alt
sind grau ihre haare sind grau mein
onkel heißt fred mein onkel heißt fried
er hat eine glatze
sein
ist hellblau sein hemd
ist hellblau seine rosa ist schwarz
seine hose ist schwarz meine tante heißt
sophie meine tante heißt sophie ihre
haare sind rot und lang
ihre haare sind rot und lang ihr kleid
ist schwarz ihr kleid ist schwarz ihr
halstuch ist dunkelblau ihr halstuch ist
dunkelblau
ich kaufe das hemd ich kaufe das hemd
ich kaufe die schuhe
ich kaufe den koffer ich kaufe den
koffer ich kaufe die hose ich kaufe die
hose ich kaufe das t shirt
ich kaufe das t shirt
ich kaufe die jacke ich kaufe die jacke
ich kaufe die krawatte ich kaufe die
krawatte
ich kaufe die socken
ich kaufe den badeanzug
ich kaufe den badeanzug ich kaufe
handtasche
ich kaufe
ich kaufe die stiefel
ich kaufe den hut ich kaufe den hut ich
kaufe den rock ich kaufe den rock ich
kaufe die halskette ich kaufe die
halskette
ich kaufe das kleid
das bild zeigt meine familie
ich stehe vorne in der mitte es ist mein
geburtstag
ich werde neun jahre alt
mein rock ist großer und mein t shirt
ist weiß meine haare sind lang und braun
ich bin klein
wir kinder stehen vorne und die
erwachsenen händen mein cousin trägt
eine brille
seine haare sind blond sein t shirt ist
gelb und seine kurze hose ist blau
meine cousine ist groß und dünn
ihre haare sind schulterlang und roth
ihre hose ist grün und ihr pullover ist
rot mein bruder trägt eine
baseball-mütze
seine jacke ist braun und seine hose ist
dunkelblau
seine haare sind schwarz
meine großeltern stehen hinten in der
mitte
mein großvater heißt hans sein hemd ist
rot und schwarz karierte
seine haare und sein bart sind grau
seine brille ist schwarz meine
großmutter heißt erika
ihre haare sind grauer pullover ist
dunkelgrau ihr t shirt und shorts in
schwarz ganz links steht meine tante
sophie
ihre haare sind lang und rot
ihr kleid und ihr schal sind schwarz
ihre haut ist sehr hell
mein onkel trägt auch eine brille
sein hemd ist hellblau und seine
krawatte ist rot und schwarz gestreift
sein bauch ist dick seine haare sind
kurz und blond
meine mutter steht ganz rechts
ihre bluse ist rot und ihr rock ist
schwarz
ihre augen sind groß und blau
mein vater hat schwarze haare
sein pullover ist braun
seine hose ist dunkelgrau und seine
schuhe sind schwarz
die hose die hosen die hose die hosen
der pullover die pullover
der pullover
die pullover das t shirt die t shirts
das t shirt die t shirts die jacke die
jacken die jacke die jacken der rock die
röcke der rock die röcke das hemmt die
händen da
die hemden die tasche die taschen die
tasche die taschen der mantel die mäntel
der mahnte die mäntel das kleid die
kleider das kleid die kleider